cette grosse demi-heure de retard mais
c'est vrai que peut-être on avait vu un
petit peu juste
en une heure et demie faire un table
ronde sur les enjeux qui se posent au
parc social en matière de rénovation
énergétique et nos interlocuteurs
étaient particulièrement
passionnant voilà on vous laisse vous
installer
donc Monsieur le Directeur ont été
heureux de vous accueillir pour cette
audition vous êtes directeur du
développement durable de l'entreprise
Schneider Electric vous occupez ce poste
depuis 2000 et vous êtes depuis 2021
vice-président citoyenneté et relation
institutionnelles de l'entreprise
ingénieur de formation vous êtes
également engagé pour l'environnement en
dehors des Schneider Electric en tant
que vice-président de la commission
Environnement du Conseil économique
social et environnementale depuis 2021
votre entreprise est spécialisée dans
les solutions numériques d'énergie et
d'automatisation elle propose notamment
et c'est ce qui nous intéresse plus
particulièrement aujourd'hui des
technologies permettant d'optimiser
l'efficacité énergétique des bâtiments
pouvez-vous de manière générale
présenter l'action de Schneider Electric
dans le domaine de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments
les solutions que vous proposez
permettent de réguler les consommations
le plus efficacement possible dans un
objectif de sobriété mais également de
prévoir les travaux qui sont nécessaires
à la rénovation énergétique quelle place
ces solutions doivent-elles selon vous
occuper dans l'objectif global de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dans le secteur du bâtiment
résidentiel l'optimisation de la
consommation d'énergie par la
technologie peut-elle compenser le trop
faible nombre de travaux de rénovation
énergétique entreprise enfin nous nous
interrogeons également
dans le cadre de cette commission
d'enquête sur la gouvernance des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
estimez-vous en tant qu'acteur de la
rénovation être suffisamment associée à
la conception et à la mise en œuvre de
cette politique publique de rénovation
énergétique quel rôle selon vous les
acteurs privés doivent-ils jouer dans
l'atteinte des objectifs de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
bâtiment avant de vous laisser la parole
pour un propos introductif il me
reviennent si vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'un compte rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45 euros d'amende à 100000 euros je
vous invite donc Monsieur le Directeur
du développement durable à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité a levé la main droite et à
dire je le jure pour faire ça
évidemment je vous laisse la parole pour
vos propos introductifs et ensuite notre
rapporteur et nos collègues ici présents
pourront vous poser un certain nombre de
questions merci beaucoup madame
sénatrice
la Présidente je comprends en entendant
toutes vos questions
que mes prédécesseurs ont été longs pour
répondre à toutes ces questions je
voudrais en propos introductif avant de
dire quelques mots sur les métiers de
Schneider Electric
dire deux choses si cette commission
avait eu lieu il y a très peu d'années
elle se serait encore appelée
rénovation thermique et pas rénovation
énergétique il y a eu un combat en 2012
pour savoir si la RT 2012 serait la re
2012 et elle a un moment
porter le nom de régulation énergétique
2012 puis finalement il est revenu à RT
2012 il a fallu attendre la dernière
pour qu'on passe de rénovation
énergétique et je pense que c'est un
point important parce que ça apporte une
cohérence globale à la notion
énergétique et ça montre dans les vingt
années qui ont vient de convient de
vivre ce premier point d'évolution
le deuxième point d'évolution c'est dans
le cadre de votre commission vous
vous invitiez Schneider Electric et
au-delà de Schneider Electric les
entreprises qui représentent ce type
d'acteurs qui sont liés un syndicat qui
s'appelle Jimenez clavier que tous
menant des des démarches similaires à
répondre à vos questions parce que au
fond c'est une un deuxième point
intéressant il est pas certain que dans
des auditions précédentes sur un sujet
similaire on se soit demandé si des
entreprises comme Schneider Electric
mais aussi
ses partenaires ses pairs avec quelque
chose à dire sur ce sujet et donc ces
deux points marquent une évolution assez
intéressante qu'il faut marquer
et qui nous amènera et j'en parlerai
plus tard à réfléchir au comportement
des habitants et aux comportements des
gestionnaires de bâtiments
premier point vous avez noté que j'étais
aussi membre du 16e alors je vais
commencer par par le 16e je suis sûr que
vous l'avez mais je peux pas ne pas le
faire le CESU a fait il y a très peu de
temps une un document sur des bâtiments
plus durables grâce à une ambition
politique de rénovation qui a été votée
par l'ensemble des groupes du CE et on
sait que parfois mettre en accord
l'ensemble des groupes associatifs
syndicaux patronaux sur un document
comme ça et sur une vingtaine de
préconisations
n'est pas chose simple et je trouve en
ayant préparé ce travail pour pour vous
qu'il y a dans ce document aussi
quelques quelques réponses à vos
questions et que le rapporteur de ce
travail
à lui-même
mener des travaux avec l'ensemble des
membres du CESU et particulièrement de
sa commission avec beaucoup d'auditions
qui qui vont dans le même sens que les
questions vous vous posez probablement
que ces documents j'en ai amené
quelques-uns peuvent être utiles et je
vous les donnerai
au fond je viens plutôt avec une
question qu'avec une réponse c'est ma
réponse mais probablement que mon
intervention amènera dans votre esprit
une question
la question est la suivante on est en
est-ce que le numérique
rebat les cartes la performance
énergétique du bâtiment est plus
généralement du système énergétique
français ou mondial
particularité de Schneider Electric
c'est une entreprise française qui agit
dans tous les pays du monde et que les
solutions qu'on met en oeuvre dans tel
ou tel pays avec d'ailleurs des
disparités entre les pays on voit le
poids des politiques publiques les
réalités énergétiques des pays les
réalités de bâtiments des pays pour voir
comment tel ou telle solution et plus
mise en oeuvre dans mon tel ou tel pays
je pourrais y revenir mais au fond la
question qu'apporte Schneider Electric
avec quelques disruptions qui peuvent
suivre c'est est-ce que
aujourd'hui
le numérique dont on voit qu'il a changé
beaucoup de pratique de nos vies dans
l'achat dans le tourisme dans la
communication dans la manière de
travailler
qu'est-ce qu'il change dans le système
énergétique d'une part et singulièrement
sur la question du bâtiment
électrique apporte une idée une
contribution
qui est dire qu'il change drastiquement
le rapport entre investissement et
performance
les propos que je vais tenir ne sont pas
là de nature à dire qu'il n'est plus
utile de ne faire aucun geste de
rénovation du bâtiment de l'isoler de
changer des fenêtres de s'occuper des
comptes etc
mais il dit quelque chose d'assez
différent
c'est que pour repérer aujourd'hui un
logement bâtiment tertiaire un bâtiment
public
avec un investissement
du 10 à 20 euros du mètre carré
on peut avoir une performance
énergétique de 20 à 50%
du bâtiment
alors de manière générale
particulièrement dans le résidentiel de
20 à 30% l'exemple de 50% que je prenais
est lié à des bâtiments très
particuliers qui sont les bâtiments
scolaires
dans lequel l'appareillage intelligent
et le pilotage numérique du bâtiment
permet et des exemples le montres et
réductions jusqu'à 50% de la
consommation énergétique nous
conviendrons ensemble qu'il y a là une
disruption de méthode entre une
réflexion quand on parle de rénovation
du bâtiment qui va de manière générale
avec un investissement
pour être très large d'au moins 200 et
plutôt 2000 euros du mètre carré
pour une performance
habituellement située entre 20 et 30%.
il y a des évidemment des cas très
différents on est dans une moyenne sur
l'ensemble des gestes posés et que moi
je viens avec un métier différent une
réalité différent de dire il suffit
d'investir 10 euros dans le même
bâtiment dans le même logement au mètre
carré pour avoir la même performance de
30%. pourquoi comment
parce que le numérique
est un outil simple de pilotage je
pourrais vous être loin de moi je vais
quand même le faire à distance vous
montrer un endroit très simple qui est
mon propre logement dans lequel je peux
à l'endroit où je suis ici vous dire
quelle est la température qui est dans
chacune des pièces aussi tout à coup
j'étais pas loin de chez moi qu'on soit
en plein hiver et que je sais que je
vais rentrer mais que mes enfants ne
sont pas là je pourrais très bien
décider que dans une pièce je mets la
température à 19 parce qu'elle n'est
qu'à 16 et parce qu'à température
n'était pas bonne ce même outil permet
de piloter évidemment la lumière
les détecteur de fumée l'ouverture de
porte ou de fenêtre etc etc et de fait
il coûte installer dans un logement
normal de
700 à 1000 euros l'ensemble des produits
qu'on est des boucles d'eau chaude ou
qu'on est du chauffage électrique en
mettant une vanne différentes connectées
en mettant sur les prix
une surprise qui permet de la connecter
aussi et en pouvant piloter ainsi
l'ensemble des consommations de votre
maison rendant du thermostat historique
l'idée d'un ancêtre qui a permis cette
évolution là
quel est l'intérêt de cette évolution
alors je vais pour prendre un exemple
très simple partir d'autant que c'est le
moment et que le ministre hier fait un
moment important sur la rénovation des
bâtiments scolaires partir
d'investissement scolaire qui est très
simple dans un bâtiment scolaire
la boucle d'eau chaude c'est de 3 à 5%
de la consommation énergétique du
bâtiment simplement pour que la boucle
d'eau chaude fonctionne 24 heures sur 24
365 jours la très grande majorité des
bâtiments scolaires n'ont pas de
pilotage de la boucle d'eau chaude elle
fonctionne tout le temps un basculement
scolaire n'est pas utilisé au moins les
deux tiers du temps si vous cumulez
les nuits les jours de semaine ou pas
utilisé les jours de vacances l'ensemble
de tous ces jours là c'est deux tiers du
temps et bah si deux tiers du temps de
5% de la consommation vous vous
l'arrêtez puisqu'elle sert à rien la
boule d'eau chaude à ce moment là vous
gagnez 2/3 de 3 à 5% de la consommation
énergétique du bien si par ailleurs vous
avez des petits connecteurs qui coûtent
chacun à moins de 10 euros sur chaque
fenêtre sur chaque porte etc et que
quand la fenêtre est ouverte durablement
forcément le chauffage ou la
climatisation s'arrête quand il y a
personne dans le bien forcément
tout ça s'arrête sauf si il y a un
asservissement le matin une demi-heure
avant l'arrivée des personnes pour que
le la classe quand elle sera utilisée
sera la température qu'il faut etc
l'ensemble de ces petits gestes de ces
pilotage automatique font passer de la
sobriété à l'efficacité parce que la
sobriété au fond c'est une prise de
conscience de chacun d'entre nous ou
d'un certain nombre d'entre nous de la
nécessité de consommer moins
et au moment où on prend cette
conscience on fait les gestes sur le
sujet
l'appareillage intelligent et le
pilotage de son bien permet de
transformer
ce moment de conscience et d'engagement
en un outil qui va se piloter
profondément j'ai été pendant tout
l'hiver dernier le pilote d'un groupe de
travail du C3d le Collectif des
directeurs du développement durable sur
la question de la sobriété dans les dans
les bâtiments tertiaires des des
entreprises membres du C3d de toute
taille
et donc il y a des efforts à faire qui
qui ont été visibles pendant l'hiver
dernier qui au fond est un moment
important qui a amené plus de crédit à
la nécessité de la nécessité
d'efficacité énergétique
et si on parle de ces bâtiments on parle
des GTB qui sont maintenant
obligatoirement installer dans chacun de
ces bâtiments qu'il soit public ou privé
parce qu'ils font plus de 1000 m²
bientôt 500 mètres carrés
10% des GTB français sont programmés
c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont installés
et l'électricité il passe comme si elle
n'existait pas
il suffit de l'installer de la
réinitialiser lorsqu'on l'a asséi pour
telle ou telle raison voilà et on a
l'économie d'énergie donc est-ce que le
numérique change la donne le numérique
change deux trois choses au moins sur
quatre points
le premier qui a beaucoup manqué à
toutes nos politiques
d'efficacité énergétique des 20
dernières années et depuis le Grenelle
singulièrement il apporte la production
de données
quand on a fait Linky on a aussi félinky
pour avoir des données
on a peu utilisé la question de la
protection de la production de données
pour établir la loi pour savoir
exactement comment on fait la loi
d'ailleurs le décret bac avec ses 250
pages qui essayent de dire
usage par usage combien faut consommer
on voit bien qu'il a été fait sans les
données initiales si on s'était donné
ça ne sert pas à grand chose à le dire
si ce n'est que ça posera quelques
jalons pour l'avenir les moyens depuis
le Grenelle de l'environnement
de produits de conserver d'analyser des
données de consommation
tels que le numérique le permet on
aurait dans toutes les réglementations
régulations décisions d'accompagnement
financier
à prendre aujourd'hui et à prolonger
dans l'avenir un outil clair pour les
rendre efficaces parce que finalement
quand on fait sans les données initiales
quelques démarches de régulation bah
forcément on tombe une fois sur deux à
côté de la réalité donc le la première
chose le numérique change en rabattant
les cartes la question de la production
des données que ce soit dans le cadre
des GTB ou dans le cas de la maison
individuelle telle qu'on le peut l'avoir
jeune
la deuxième chose c'est que le numérique
comme je venais de le montrer
permet le contrôle de la consommation au
plus près
au plus près de ma présence au plus près
de la température extérieure
au plus près de l'usage que je veux
avoir de tel ou telle pièce et permet
d'individualiser chaque lieu de
consommation
à nouveau qu'on est une production de
chaleur s'il est question du chauffage
de n'importe quel manière que ce soit
évidemment c'est plus efficace si
celui-ci est électrique j'ai reviendrai
le troisième point c'est qu'il permet la
flexibilité d'usage
et le quatrième point c'est que dans les
règles d'aujourd'hui il permet
de définir l'étape de demain je
m'explique
si chacun d'entre nous
dans une logique de prospective on avait
la qualité de dessinateur et la capacité
de dessiner la ville la maison le
bâtiment de 2050
il aurait au moins deux particularités
j'en suis sûr
il serait tout électrique et il aurait
une production indépendante d'une partie
de son énergie
en particulier par des moyens solaires
je pense que n'importe qui qui
aujourd'hui dessinerait ce bâtiment là
le dessinerait comme ça comment on
produit quand pour cent de bâtiment par
an de logement
ça veut dire qu'une bonne partie des
logements demain vont être à rénovés
puisqu'ils sont déjà là et que tous ceux
qui sont à produire aujourd'hui doivent
prendre en compte ce sujet
y compris en rendant le bâtiment comme
la pièce centrale de la flexibilité
il arrive encore aujourd'hui
qu'on produise des logements
avec un parking souterrain sans prise
électrique dans ce parking alors qu'on
sait tous que le produisant aujourd'hui
il devrait encore être en vie au moment
où on a considéré tous les véhicules
seraient électriques on pourra
certainement l'installer enfin se dire
aujourd'hui qui est régulation n'impose
pas pour des biens nouveaux suffisamment
ce qui est une évidence dans les
programmations pluriannuelles et dans la
vision qu'on a de l'ensemble des
engagements qu'on prend soit comme pays
soit dans le cadre des obligations
européennes est assez étonnant
donc la flexibilité ces solutions
utilisables par chacun aujourd'hui on a
vu d'ailleurs on pourrait avoir une
critique historique surtout l'usage du
numérique la séparation
à la fois liée aux générations et à la
fois liée
à la réalité socio-économique des
familles
on sait dire aujourd'hui singulièrement
après le covid
que chacun ou une grande partie de la
population suffisamment importante c'est
utiliser cet outil là
que cet outil là de génération en
génération est de plus en plus
conviviale conversationnel facile à
utiliser que les grands-parents ont su
faire des entretiens vidéo avec leurs
petits-enfants pendant le covid etc etc
tout ça poussant une société complète à
devenir plus mature sur l'usage de ce
produit qu'il faut évidemment encadrer
mais qui est aujourd'hui central dans la
démarche donc
notre vision est la suivante
il nous faut aujourd'hui dans les
rénovations
et dans les constructions
pensez à ce que sera demain notre
consommation notre bâtiment et faire en
sorte qu'à chaque fois on puisse y
installer le bâtiment comme lieu de la
flexibilité générale d'un dialogue entre
l'offre et la demande et c'est en ce
sens là qu'il faut le penser
différemment il me semble qu'on a deux
systèmes de pensée qui doivent
aujourd'hui au regard de ces cartes qui
se rebattent être réfléchi ensemble
celui de l'énergie et de la manière de
produire d'énergie puis celui de la
consommation singulièrement quand on
parle aujourd'hui de la du mix
énergétique ou de politique énergétique
du pays on ne parle que de sa production
est-ce qu'elle est produite de cette
manière là de cette manière-là de cette
manière là et ce qu'on en produit assez
pour être au-delà de la crête de l'an
dernier il y a des règles sur le sujet
et on investit pour produire davantage
si on prenait sérieusement la vision
d'une capacité de baisser la
consommation énergétique du bâtiment de
30%
et qu'on investissait sur ce sujet là
non comme la cerise sur le gâteau mais
comme une part première de
l'investissement énergétique
et qu'on considérait au fond
l'efficacité énergétique ou la réduction
de la consommation énergétique comme
l'une des données de production
par entière avec les autres on amènerait
des réflexions de réduction de
l'investissement pour production de même
hauteur
on émettrait moins on consommerait moins
et on qualifierait nos biens
premier point et donc le logement le
bâtiment est à considérer demain dans sa
flexibilité d'usage il y a déjà des pays
qui le mettent en oeuvre comme ça donc
je suis pas en train de raconter le
monde du 22 du 22e siècle qui n'arrivera
jamais dans lequel et vous savez qu'il y
a des régulations qui imposent ça pour
2025 le la batterie de la voiture peut
devenir
le producteur énergétique puisqu'on
pourra demain on devra demain faire en
sorte que le chargeur de batterie puisse
aller dans les deux sens et que la
batterie puisse se charger décharger
dans les deux sens et donc c'est une
manière évidemment de penser qu'au
moment de la pointe parce qu'au fond la
grande question la grande question
énergétique française ou mondiale mais
en tous les cas françaises c'est les
1000 heures de pointe
les réduire c'est réduire profondément
les émissions de carbone puisque j'ai
plus de chiffre en tête mais c'est 1000
heures de plein de pointes je crois
c'est plus de la moitié peut-être même
des deux tiers des émissions carbone de
l'électricité française premier point et
donc si on sait à ce moment là faire de
la flexibilité de l'effacement
évidemment on réduit la consommation
énergétique au moment le plus important
où il faut la réduire c'est à dire qu'il
faut à la fois avoir un système qui
permet de la réduire tout le temps
et drastiquement au moment où il faut
vraiment la réduire parce que il fait
plus froid parce que etc etc je suis pas
futuriste en disant que le numérique le
lien avec le réseau le lien avec Linky
qui a été installé cette génération là
est probablement les générations qui
suivront permettra de faire ça permettra
de faire en sorte que l'effacement la
flexibilité soit une des données de la
sécurité électrique du pays
deuxième point c'est que de fait je
pense que dans l'ensemble des
des outils que se donne la puissance
publique pour accompagner la rénovation
du bâtiment une bonne partie de ces
outils finances l'évolution des chaudias
je crois que c'est ma prime rénov c'est
plus de des deux tiers de ma prise rénov
qui va sur les chaudières
il nous apparaît
qu'on devrait pouvoir réfléchir d'autant
que la France est en train de se doter
de l'appareil industriel pour le faire
du passage direct au tout électrique et
de ne financer que de ne subventionner
que cette démarche là je sais que tous
les industriels ne disent pas cela mais
si vous veniez
interroger une filière
de très grande qualité française qu'elle
a filière de production
de chaudières gaz française qui est une
des premières filières au niveau
européen et qui est une référence
mondiale l'ensemble de ces acteurs
industriels sont en train de produire
des pompes à chaleur
sont en train eux-mêmes de faire cette
transition accompagner encore plus vite
cette transition me semble-t-il
permettra un
d'arriver à une énergie la moins
carbonée possible c'est-à-dire l'énergie
électrique et singulièrement quand on
est en France
deux d'avoir des systèmes qui partout
autorisent l'autoconsommation
et d'utiliser l'autoconsommation comme
un outil d'efficacité énergétique j'en
viendrai avec quelques références
et trois nous amener directement dès
maintenant à la proximité du dessin que
chacun d'entre nous aurait fait si
jamais on avait destiné la ville de
demain
sans prolonger des produits qui ont
montré leur efficacité dans un cadre
différent mais qui probablement
aujourd'hui par la puissance publique
sont à faire évoluer
pourquoi l'autre consommation est un
outil sérieux de notre démarche
je vous invite à regarder une démarche
anglaise
ou la précarité énergétique est plus
importante qu'en France pour plein de
raisons qu'on connaît
d'éclates pour du système etc je crois
qu'on a on s'est mesuré quand l'angle
quand ce pays était dans la communion
européenne dans la Communauté européenne
que le pourcentage de gens précarité
énergétique je crois qu'on dit que c'est
18% en France maintenant dans une autre
mesure c'est 10% à chaque fois les
Anglais c'était au moins la moitié de
plus
ils ont fait une démarche très
intéressante c'est que sur un nombre
significatif
de logement
comme j'ai prêté serment je peux pas
dire de chiffres j'ai pas besoin de me
tromper sur un nombre significatif de
logement ils ont proposé aux personnes
en précarité énergétique
d'installer des panneaux photovolates
photosvoltaïques de production ce qui a
eu comme conséquence de diminuer par
deux leur consommation énergétique et
comme deuxième conséquence de les rendre
plus attentifs à cette démarche dans le
jeu de je produis je consomme combien je
produis combien je consomme comment
optimiser ma consommation pour accroître
ma production dans celle-ci et au fond
que ça marche exactement pour tous les
ménages français qui font de
l'autoconsommation
quand tout à coup
un ménage est en capacité de faire une
petite production de sa consommation
énergétique
d'avoir un système lui permettant de
mesurer ce qui produit de mesurer ce qui
consomme
il a en face de la question de
l'efficacité énergétique une vision
assez différente et une capacité et
cette étudiée et
des études montrent ça et une capacité
de s'engager davantage dans la dans
l'efficacité énergétique assez
importante
tout ça amène une évolution assez forte
des politiques publiques françaises
pour se rapprocher de politique publique
quand elles existent du nord de l'Europe
qui font confiance à une logique
comportementaliste
la politique publique française
d'efficacité énergétique n'est jamais en
rien comportementaliste elle préfère des
gestes lourds les considères efficaces
quand ils sont très lourds
alors même que
quand je dis que le numérique rabat les
cartes
il permet de privilégier les Quick win
les les apports rapides
si tout à coup en investissant
simplement
dit à 20 euros du mètre carré pour
réduire de 20% sa consommation
énergétique
on voit bien qu'on a un retour sur
investissement de moins de 5 ans
dans quelques lieux que j'ai cité
parfois de moins de 2 ans et moins de 3
ans
il permet donc de faire des économies
pour refaire son bien y compris sur des
enjeux d'isolation
etc qui permettront de conserver ou
d'accroître sa valeur mais qu'en plus
cet effet là que l'effet d'efficacité
énergétique
si tout à coup
on appelait
20 fois moins d'argent public
pour gagner
20% d'efficacité énergétique on pourrait
faire 20 fois plus de gestes
et probablement embarquer
plus de citoyens dans cette démarche
j'ajoute qu'elle a une petite
particulière une partie de particularité
qui n'est pas complètement indéniable
c'est qu'elle n'empêche pas l'usage
pendant la rénovation
très souvent les rénovations lourdes
particulièrement
je vais reprendre l'idée du bâtiment de
scolaire pas une rénovation lourde et en
même temps faut trouver un autre espace
retrouver ou même des rénovations de
logements un peu lourdes
une installation d'une solution
depuis l'otage intelligent de votre
logement ou maison ne vous impose pas de
l'abandonner quelques jours
mais peut se faire pendant qu'il est en
usage
sujet qui n'est pas complètement en
compte peu de battement
sans importance
et il permet chacun d'autant
qu'aujourd'hui les personnes sont plus
sensibilisées que dans le passé et
singulièrement après l'hiver 22 et la
communication qui a été faite sur ce
sujet là il permet à chacun mieux
sensibiliser
dans cette approche comportementaliste
d'être dans une logique avec la
puissance publique de confiance et on
considérant que il n'est pas que
question de changer le bâti parce qu'on
changera pas la vie on changera pas la
mobilisation ou la manière de vivre des
Français et des françaises mais qu'on
peut aussi dans une logique
d'accompagnement des comportements des
évolutions des comportements que le
numérique va permettre
d'automatiser
l'industrialiser à bas coût
d'avoir quelques quelques points
l'autre point qui me fait sortir du
bâtiment et comme je viens de le faire
une fois en disant quand on pense le
bâtiment de demain et le financement de
son et une évolution de sa révolution
pour son efficacité énergétique il faut
le penser en dynamique dans son usage et
pas seulement dans le fait qu'il existe
premièrement et deuxièmement en
cohérence avec toutes les politiques
énergétiques pour faire un lien entre la
production énergétique y compris
répartie et décentralisé et la nécessité
de réduire la pointe
deuxième point ce bâtiment devient la
brique centrale de la relation y compris
avec le transport que je disais sur les
véhicules électriques qu'il conviennent
penser en même temps qu'on pense la
rénovation du bâtiment un autre point
important pour dire le plus rapidement
possible les politiques publiques
doivent conduire en toute électrique
et puis
un troisième point c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de bâtiments privés il y a
aussi quelques bâtiments publics
l'ensemble des sujets dont on parle
qu'il soit dans le logement ou dans le
bâtiment tertiaire doit pousser l'état
régulateur à le Grenelle l'avait invité
à le faire à être aussi un peu
exemplaire sur le sujet et c'est
exemplarité d'un
dans le bâtiment tertiaire le bâtiment
public représente le croit le tiers
du bâtiment tertiaire je crois que ça
représente 400 millions de mètres carrés
un tiers par l'État et 2/3 par les
collectivités territoriales ou ou
structure d'État
et donc on voit bien comment il y a là
tout un travail et je finirai par ce
point là qui nous invite à la réflexion
sur les compétences
et là aussi
la puissance publique a un rôle central
en particulier sur l'acquisition des
compétences que ce soit l'acquisition
des compétences
de l'élève de celui qui choisit son
métier qui comprend que ce métier là est
à la fois un métier noble qui a un
impact qui peut lui permettre de de
construire sa vie et de mettre le pied à
l'étrier
premier point et puis deuxième point
dans l'établissement de système
d'accompagnement de l'évolution des
compétences des salariés du moment par
exemple en ayant des systèmes invitant à
trouver un remplaçant quand un salarié
acquiert des compétences puisqu'il est
question d'apprentissage des cours en
faibles au milieu des cours en forts etc
etc je pense que cette question des
compétences et je pense que les métiers
dont je parle et de leur attractivité
de ce que représente l'électricité
numérique
pour des jeunes et dans la capacité de
les capter pour qu'il puisse rentrer
dans ce style de métier est un sujet
tout à fait capital et quelque part
en même temps
qui est en capacité de mener des
politiques publiques
qui ne s'attachent pas simplement
à financer des gestes parce qu'ils sont
lourds mais à financer des gestes parce
qu'ils sont utiles dans l'efficacité
énergétique
y compris et je peux en convenir qu'il y
ait plus compliqué de financer beaucoup
de petits gestes que quelques grands
gestes
en même temps en accroissant et en
rendant plus attractif l'ensemble de ces
métiers de la formation asmetier on
créera une capacité de dire je veux pas
faire de supprimer l'idée qu'on ne fera
pas ce geste là parce qu'il sera trop
dur de trouver le professionnel pour le
poser
et que on est là dans une logique
vertueuse de deuxième point voilà un peu
l'apport de des entreprises telles que
je connais des électriques et tous les
autres à la fois sur un sujet qui
historiquement plutôt été réservés au
bâtiment tertiaires
GTB et qui aujourd'hui au quart du
numérique des prises de conscience des
sensibilisations peut tout à fait
trouver sa place au cœur des politiques
publiques
poussant à la à
l'efficacité énergétique doit d'ailleurs
dans ce pays plus que dans d'autres les
trouver parce que plus que dans d'autres
le législateur
est très intrusif dans ces politiques
énergétiques je crois pouvoir dire qu'il
n'y a pas d'autres exemples que la
France
dans lequel le législateur tous les ans
décide et chaque année différemment
qu'est-ce qu'il subventionne
et comment il le subventionne il y a 12
ans
dans ma maison j'habite Nanterre j'ai
refait
mon chauffage et mon eau chaude et le
législateur avait décidé cette année-là
qu'il va aller mieux
séparer la production d'eau chaude de la
production de chauffage et installée à
la fois une pompe à chaleur pour l'eau
chaude et à la fois une chaudière pour
le chauffage et que si je faisais ça
j'avais 40% de déduction fiscale alors
que si j'achetais qu'une seule chaudière
qui faisait les deux je n'avais 30 % de
déduction fiscale il a sûrement une
bonne année cette année-là il se trouve
qu'il n'avait pas eu l'année d'avant il
n'a pas eu l'année d'après il n'a plus
jamais eu il y a pas de pays au monde où
jusqu'ici loin
le législateur n'est pas agnostique sous
les solutions techniques mais les
définis précisément il se trouve que
deux ans après pendant une année et
seulement une année et grâce à et merci
que ça soit qu'une année il avait aussi
décidé de ne plus financer les
thermostats de chauffage
qui parce que pas assez coûteux
devaient pas soutenir etc ce qui pose
une question est-ce qu'il doit continuer
à faire comme ça peut-être qu'en France
oui la manière dont la France est
organisée faite peut-être que il faut
aller jusque là mais dans ce cas là
il doit trouver un geste pour financer
l'accompagnement l'évolution du
comportement des gens parce qu'après
c'est bien normal et je pense que
l'ADEME doit prendre un plus grand rôle
qu'il le prend sur ce sujet on peut
considérer que l'ADEME aurait dû avoir
cet hiver un rôle plus important dans
tous les plans de sobriété et être plus
entendu qu'il a été c'est pas forcément
la dame qu'on a pu s'entendu cet hiver
mais on peut comprendre que tous les les
salariés de l'ADEME qui reçoivent les
Français et les Françaises pour les
accompagner dans leur gestes
d'efficacité énergétique quand une
solution comme celle que je vous
présente parce qu'elle n'est pas assez
coûteuse n'est pas accompagnée
financièrement par la puissance publique
jamais ces salariés vont expliquer aux
Français aux Français ce qui peuvent
l'utiliser je les imagine assez à dire
écoutez vous avez cette solution 1
vous serez accompagné de 30% mais il y a
aussi cette solution 2 elle est très
très bien mais vous ne serez pas
accompagné on peut imaginer que le
français dise voilà ça doit pas bien
marcher donc il me semble que dans le
mode de fonctionnement français
qui accompagne la rénovation du bâtiment
et l'efficacité énergétique par des
inits senti fortes plus forte
qu'ailleurs
il doit considérer ce type de geste même
si c'est plus complexe de le financer
parce qu'il est moins cher
et plus vite rentable sinon il sera pas
installé je peux vous dire que dans
l'expérience de Schneider Electric c'est
une solution que je vous ai montré pour
le résidentiel qui s'appelle whizer et
bien plus installé dans les pays où il
n'y a pas d'accompagnement public à la
réduction de la consommation énergétique
parce que quand la personne est tout
seul face on investissement et cherche
son efficacité il prendra celle là
puisqu'il n'est pas accompagné pour
d'autres je suis pas en train de vous
dire qu'il ne faut pas accompagner
l'efficacité énergétique je suis en
train de vous dire que si la puissance
publique
ne considère pas que le numérique
reballé carte de l'efficacité
énergétique
alors il les rabattra beaucoup moins il
rabattra beaucoup moins en France
qu'ailleurs puisqu'il a un rôle puisque
cette puissance publique a un rôle
éducatif de sensibilisation et
d'accompagnement des professions et des
solutions installées et des gestes
installés plus importants de qu'ailleurs
ou alors dans une période transitoire on
pourrait imaginer
et des études le montrent que quand on
fait les deux gestes un geste
d'efficacité énergétique passive
accompagnée
parce qu'il est subventionné par un
geste d'efficacité énergétique active
qui au fond de rapportera ne rajoute pas
grand chose à la facture
une étude qui avait été faite par
carbone kan montrer que le cumul des
deux gestes rendait le tout plus
efficace parce que les gens étaient plus
attentifs voilà
votre disposition pour des questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
c'est à vous
merci madame la Présidente merci pour
ces le directeur pour ces explications
très très riches je pense que je sais
pas combien on a de temps parce que
c'est vrai on a envie de
rentrer dans la dans la discussion
non peut-être plusieurs déjà peut-être
plusieurs remarques par rapport à ce que
ce que vous dites là sur le fait est-ce
que ce que du coup là à votre question
de démarrage en tout cas est-ce que le
numérique reballe et les cartes du
système énergétique dans le bâtiment
[Musique]
comme ça en tout cas même on vous
écoutant je sais pas franchement
répondre à la répondre à la question
c'est vrai que dans ce que vous avez pu
dire je trouve qu'il y a des choses un
petit peu contradictoires ce qu'on voit
là où je suis où je suis d'accord avec
vous sur la maison 2050 enfin si on
dessinait aussi on pas forcément celle
qui aura mais celle qu'on dessine
aujourd'hui avec les éléments qu'on peut
avoir je pense que c'est surtout
l'indépendance l'autonomie et le fait
que on dépende de rien d'autre je pense
qu'il y a aussi lié à
une moindre confiance au service public
une moindre confiance en l'alimentation
électrique etc et donc de se dire il
faut que j'ai quelque chose sur lequel
je sois totalement autonome et donc je
ne dépend de personnes et donc la
question du coup du numérique est aussi
une dépendance donc je pense qu'il y a
aussi cette cette question cette
question là et puisque vous avez aussi
sur le fait que la diminution de
consommation elle était liée en fait à
la à l'usage et que justement quand on
était producteur de son énergie c'est à
dire quelqu'un qui est effectivement
étant consommation qui va voir sa
consommation et donc ses dépenses va du
coup être beaucoup plus raisonnable sur
ces consommations on va faire attention
je suis pas sûr que ça soit réellement
lié au numérique en tout cas c'est lié
au fait que on voit ce qu'on produit
mais de la même manière ma grand-mère
quand elle avait son poêle à bois elle
faisait très attention à combien de buts
elle mettait dans dans le feu quand
est-ce qu'elle l'arrêtait le soir et
cetera pour le redémarrer le lendemain
matin donc on est bien sur ces questions
ces questions d'usage et pourtant il y
avait pas de il y avait pas de numérique
donc c'est pour ça que je tempérer après
sur le sur l'intérêt du numérique par
contre sur le fait
d'agir sur ces économies d'énergie ça
oui je pense ça incontestable c'est à
dire que je pense que quand on arrive à
mettre en place des outils effectivement
qu'on me dites qui coûtent peu et qui
nous permettent de faire des enfin du
pilotage et du coup de mieux utiliser en
fait l'énergie qu'on a besoin c'est un
concert je pense qu'il y a des il y a du
coup des résultats qui sont tout à fait
tout à fait important mais c'est vrai
que dans le sujet sur lequel on parle je
pense qu'il y a pas que ça parce qu'on
peut être dans une passoire thermique on
va dire un logement on va dire un digne
ou
on peut effectivement faire diminuer la
consommation parce que ben voilà on va
on va on va piloter on va faire en sorte
que quand la personne n'est pas là le
bâtiment soit pas chauffée etc enfin bon
tout ce pilotage là pour autant on
n'aura pas réglé les problèmes de santé
d'insalubrité d'humidité de ventilation
etc etc donc et même de confort Parce
que c'est vrai que même en chauffant à
22 23 degrés dans une maison qui est
mal isolée où on a différents de
température dans la maison ben on a un
confort qui est qui n'est pas bon et
donc on réglera pas du coup toute cette
problématique là c'est pour ça que je
pense que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
les les deux et qui me semble pas du
coup que cette intervention sur des
bâtiments qui soient on va dire très
dégradé sur lequel il faudrait vraiment
intervenir règle en fait vraiment le
problème
forcément peut-être faire diminuer un
petit peu la consommation énergétique ce
sont pas que ça soit totalement
suffisant l'autre aspect c'est la
question de mais vous les en avez un peu
parlé de la maintenance et de
l'accompagnement et de la pédagogie
autour de ces outils quoi pour avoir vu
quelques on parlait du scolaire quelques
groupes scolaires qui ont fonctionné
notamment par pilotage etc on peut dire
que quand ça fonctionne bien tout va
bien c'est à dire que le truc est piloté
et puis que les années passent et puis
en fait il y a pas de il y a pas de
maintenance donc le truc ne fonctionne
plus et puis bah là c'est une
catastrophe c'est à dire que on avait
une utilisation qui marche pas on a le
chauffage qui est complètement déréglé
etc et on se retrouve avec des
consommations qui sont beaucoup plus
importantes donc c'est vrai que c'est du
coup cette question de maintenance elle
est importante et en comparaison j'ai
aussi vu par exemple un exemple de
collège qui avait travaillé sur la
ventilation la ventilation totalement
naturelle
versus justement un autre qui était
totalement totalement piloté c'est vrai
que celui qui était totalement naturel
avec du coup l'usage pareil avec un
apprentissage aussi sur sur l'usage
c'est vrai qu'au bout du compte ben oui
il y a pas il y a pas de ventilation
donc oui il y a une économie il y a pas
de problématique d'arrêt ou de
redémarrage parce que bah c'est ouvrir
une fenêtre sur une coursive etc enfin
bon pas entrer dans le détail mais du
coup il y a aussi ces aspects là quoi
c'est-à-dire aussi comment on va
concevoir et on va faire en sorte que on
va être aussi du coup plus sobre donc
pour moi il y a c'est pas l'un sans
l'autre en fait évidemment le numérique
est une pièce qui est importante et qui
permet de piloter mais à condition aussi
qu'on travaille sur cette du coup sur
cette on va dire cet usage
ça c'était plus des remarques non sur
les sur les questions j'en avais d'abord
savoir si sur le travail que vous avez
pu faire et sur cette question du
pilotage est-ce que vous avez été
associé enfin en tout cas sur la
question du DPE
et notamment est-ce que enfin voilà il y
a eu des discussions et comment on
aurait pu en tout cas prendre en compte
on pourrait prendre en compte cette
question là parce que c'est vrai qu'elle
peut être intéressante aussi et donc sur
les dispositifs que vous pouvez que vous
proposer
et puis également sur mon accompagnateur
Renov qui vient d'être mis en place
savoir si c'est aussi des éléments en
tout cas sur lequel
qui pourrait être porté et puis savoir
aussi si du coup votre fin Schneider
Electric pourrait
être ou en tout cas envisage-t-il de de
faire une demande d'agrément mon
accompagnateur Renov parce que c'est
vrai que ça pourrait être pour le coup
dans vos compétences quand on voit
l'orientation qui peut être donné de
s'accompagnateur Renov et donc voilà
savoir si c'est quelque chose que vous
avez pu que vous avez pu imaginer voilà
pour l'instant sur les questions merci
ce qui est super monsieur le rapporteur
c'est que
dans vos questions
et à toutes les questions
d'inquiétude sur le numérique et demi de
mise en doute de son potentiel apport et
je pourrais dire quelque chose sur
d'autres choses sur vos sur vos
remarques
est-ce que les personnes
qui mettent des panneaux photovoltaïques
ne sont simplement dans cette démarche
parce qu'ils font pas confiance à la
puissance publique que ils veulent
s'autoriser je ne le crois pas
je pense que le 21e siècle et le siècle
du circulaire et que dans un monde
circulaire on apprend aux gens d'être
producteurs et consommateurs
on invite les gens et on voit très bien
les évolutions aujourd'hui chacun
[Musique]
avoir un petit jardin
y compris
à recycler etc de rentrer dans cette
logique
qui quitte le linéaire dans lequel on a
produit la battre très loin on a
transporté et moi je ne suis que
consommateur puis je jetterais c'est
vrai pour beaucoup prendre l'activité il
y a pas de raison que les gens qu'on
amène surtout les jeux de ménage dans
cette logique là ne se disent pas que
sur l'énergie il y a aussi une évolution
qui les rend aussi dans cette logique de
vouloir être circulaire
et par ailleurs comme le solaire vient
diminuer de
l'installation solaire donc moi
qui vient de diviser son prix par 10 en
10 ans pour arriver à Paris et dans
beaucoup de pays du monde et de
l'énergie la moins chère je rappelle que
quand on prend les chiffres de laie la
plus grande additionnalité de production
électrique mondiale et solaire et ceci
depuis plusieurs années et qu'on a là
toute une industrie
de l'autoconsommation
hyperpuissante hyper efficace qui pose
des problèmes mais lequel n'en pose pas
j'entends toutes les limites dont vous
parlez mais on a aussi les mêmes limites
on pourrait les citer quand on change sa
chaudière avant d'avoir isolé ils sont
bien et qu'on a acheté une chaudière
bien trop puissante par rapport à la
consommation d'après et les conséquences
que ça aura à la fois sur la puissance
publique le coût de de la démolition
tout ça je pense beaucoup à énergétique
alors je suis pas sur ce sujet là
Schneider est la seule entreprise qui
participe à la démarche stop à
l'exclusion énergétique tous les autres
ont des ONG plus le Schneider Electric
là quand je parle d'électricité
numérique je parle pas forcément
d'efficacité je peux convenir que pour
au moins 10% c'est à dire la moitié des
personnes en précarité énergétique qui
sont de la passoire énergétique la
solution dont je vous parle ne
fonctionne pas si elle fonctionnait sur
80% des autres personnes si elle
invitait suivant les chiffres que je
vous dis à réduire profondément le coût
pour la puissance publique de baisser de
20% la consommation énergétique des 80%
de logements qui ne sont pas en
précarité énergétique elle permettrait à
cette même puissance publique d'avoir un
peu plus d'argent pour rénover les
patients pour un nouvel espace c'est pas
parce que la solution dont numérique
n'est probablement pas la plus adaptée à
la rénovation des passoires dans lequel
il faut changer profondément le bâti
qu'il faut oublier qu'elle est
profondément adaptés aux 80% des autres
rénovations de telle sorte qu'on obtient
nos 20% d'efficacité énergétique
qu'on réduit d'au moins 20 fois le coût
pour la puissance publique puisque on
voit que la solution est beaucoup moins
chère et que cet argent peut tout à fait
être mis à profit d'une rénovation des
passoires thermiques qui n'est pas assez
importante aujourd'hui j'ajoute que sur
l'électricité passe sur thermique pour
participer à cette démarche 60 000
départs d'incendie se font dans les
passoires thermiques en France c'est pas
moi qui le dit mais c'est le consuel et
que la question de la sécurité
électrique dépasseoirs thermiques est un
sous sujet qui n'est pas complètement
nul c'était pas le sujet de notre
discussion mais au fond ça vaut le coup
quand on les rénove elles prennent pas
feu après et donc il y a un petit sujet
qui est pas complètement négligeable sur
ce sujet la solution peut pas être
efficace pour tout le monde je dis
simplement quand je dis rabattre les
cartes c'est que si la grande question
d'une politique d'efficacité énergétique
et l'impact
ça ne se mesure pas
en couple ça a coûté à la collectivité
ça se mesure en réduction de la
consommation énergétique pour réduire la
consommation énergétique il faut la
mesurer pour savoir ce qu'on réduit pour
savoir quelle est la base et quelle est
l'arrivée et puis deuxièmement faut être
surtout attentif à cette réduction et
pas au coût que on a investi pour
obtenir une réduction et pas mesurer le
coup vous savez comme moi que
la RT 2012 dont il a été dont j'ai parlé
ou la REVEA dont on parle maintenant
apporte un certain nombre de
d'obligations et que
si elles ne sont pas respectées il y a
pas beaucoup
de dommages collatéraux je pense que nos
politiques doivent conduire à mesurer
l'impact de ce qu'elles ont produit et
l'impact des solutions
suffisamment de pièces et de mesure
voilà
de fait je partage avec vous l'idée que
ces solutions qui apportent cet impact à
très moindre coût
mérite
d'avoir plus de maintenance je parlais
de nouvelles compétences de nouveaux
métiers et je pense que lorsqu'on sait
que ces solutions permettent de diminuer
30 à 40% la consommation énergétique on
doit pouvoir se dire ça vaut le coup
d'investir pour qu'une personne
puisse sur un certain nombre de lieux
dans une collectivité puisque vous me
parliez des écoles comme je l'avais fait
pour toutes les écoles etc est incapable
est en capacité
organiser là maintenant pour avoir la
performance qui était qui était désiré
donc un point sur sur l'impact un autre
point sur l'économie circulaire qui doit
rentrer aussi dans la réalité de des
sujets dont il était question
aujourd'hui même si on voit qu'il est
rentré plus tard
et je suis bien d'accord avec vous entre
votre grand-mère et mes enfants
c'est que votre grand-mère faisait
attention elle avait son poids elle
allait chercher son bois
et que
le numérique aujourd'hui alors même que
plus personne ne fait attention à sa
consommation permet au moins de savoir
ce qu'on consomme quel est
l'ustensiles la pièce l'acte qui fait le
plus consommer dans son bien et que
plutôt que de réinviter chacun à mettre
un poêle à bois et aller chercher son
bois pour pour être efficace
probablement qu'il est le seul outil
aujourd'hui qui permet de savoir
exactement ce qu'on consomme ce qui
n'empêche pas d'avoir d'autres actes
pour diminuer alors je vais répondre à
vos deux sujets
mon accompagnateur rénove non pour une
raison très précise Schneider est un
fournisseur de technologie
donc nous on permet aux acteurs
aujourd'hui
de technologie que ce soit électrique
soit des très grands acteurs comme Vinci
énergie Eiffage etc ou des acteurs comme
Cofely enfin dans une énergie
je crois que c'est le nouveau nom de
cofelly ou Dalkia ou l'électricien du
coin d'avoir les solutions techniques
pour les installer chez les habitants
donc je n'ai un peu pas prendre la place
ou le rôle de de ses clients la démarche
que la nôtre c'est de faire en sorte que
quand ces acteurs là veulent accompagner
leurs clients pour être efficace on
produise nous-mêmes
les solutions technologiques
rénovées chaque année pour répondre à
ces à ses besoins-là et que de fait
notre mini à nous c'est de produire des
technologies et pas de et pas de
désinstaller donc on peut pas être dans
cette dans ce rôle là et quand on despe
en tous les cas j'ai envie de dire que
vous l'avez appelé madame la Présidente
je suis dans ce métier dans cette
relation en particulier en France avec
la puissance publique depuis longtemps
ces sujets sont abordés depuis un
certain temps le gymélec qui est le
syndicat des des entreprises qui fait le
métier de Schneider Electric avait
produit en 2013
un document qui s'appelle je peux vous
le réadresser efficacité énergétique de
points l'outil majeur de la transition
énergétique
alors probablement que c'était trop
avant-coureur à l'époque et
les solutions n'étaient pas matures
comme elles le sont aujourd'hui les
questions non plus et les choix non plus
on a souvent fait des politiques
énergétiques ou d'efficacité énergétique
pour maintenir l'emploi ou pour soutenir
l'emploi en ayant pas forcément
le regard premier sur
quel était l'impact d'efficacité
énergétique et le produisait je pense
que c'est d'ailleurs un sujet important
l'emploi je suis venu dessus à la fin je
me rappelle très bien que pendant de
nombreuses années lorsque je présentais
ce type de solution à la puissance
publique la première question qui venait
c'était combien d'emplois ça crée
ce qui est une très belle question et en
particulier dans ces époques-là de
chômage bien plus fort qu'aujourd'hui je
comprends très bien qu'elle était
centrale probablement qu'on est en train
de redessiner l'emploi différemment dans
la décade qui vient et probablement que
on regarde des enjeux de carbone on
regarde des enjeux de production
énergétique et électrique française
toutes nos toutes nos politiques et nos
démarches individuelles ou collectives
se voient un peu différemment et c'est
là où je pense que plus de maturité à la
fois des producteurs de technologie et
plus de maturité des utilisateurs quant
à leur capacité des utiliser d'une part
et on s'en stage je suis pas sûr que
l'évaluation de dysfonctionnement du
passé soit très efficace pour
aujourd'hui on peut chacun essayer de se
rappeler les dysfonctionnements de son
premier téléphone portable ça dit pas
grand chose sur l'usage de celui
d'aujourd'hui il en est de même sur les
GTB 150 ans par rapport à celle
d'aujourd'hui les utilisateurs de vidéos
conférences de team etc qui se rappelle
comme moi il les utilisaient avant 2020
c'est à dire avant la période covid et
comment ils utilisent aujourd'hui savent
très bien que un et les utilise mieux
que deux le système est bien meilleur et
que 3 il y a plus beaucoup toutes ces
réunions dans laquelle on n'arrive pas à
se connecter donc oui vous avez raison
tout ça est en chemin je crois que le
chemin montre d'année en année des
progrès et que tous les
dysfonctionnements du passé
j'étais dans les premiers à avoir un
véculé électrique je vous promets que
les premières années de mon véhicule
électrique me donnent pas les meilleurs
souvenirs que j'ai j'ai toujours un
véhicule électrique il a plu aucun
rapport avec celui que j'avais à
l'époque il en est de même sur la
gestion intelligente du bâtiment qui
soit résidentiel collective ou ou
individuel je pense qu'on a là une
maturité qu'on n'avait pas dans le passé
que cette maturité permet lorsqu'elle
sera mesurée sur l'impact de dépasser
largement les 60 000 logements qu'on a
fait depuis 2017
pour qu'il soit plus efficace sur les
500 000 ou 600 000 qu'on s'est évoqués
et que ces solutions devraient
dans leur installation dans le pilotage
dans le suivi l'évaluation et je suis le
premier à vouloir qui est de
l'évaluation de ce dont je vous parle
permet de plus rapidement à avoir
beaucoup plus de bâtiments qui
consomment beaucoup moins ça me paraît
logique que
lorsqu'il était soit des passoires
thermiques et d'évolution
réglementaires sur le sujet la
complexité de vendre etc j'ai envie de
dire ces solutions là à bas coût
permet d'aller plus vite sur des
rénovations
qu'à la fois en nommé en femme
capable de les mener en moyen capable
d'être
dépensé parce que lorsque l'on dit pour
des ménages modestes con subventionnent
largement le geste de rénovation on
n'oublie pas que
il y a quand même un reste à charge qui
est assez important pour la plupart
d'entre eux même s'il y a quelques
exceptions et qui sont pas en mesure de
le donner
le ménage plutôt plus aisé va faire ses
actes pas tant pour l'efficacité
énergétique pour l'encharissement ou de
son bien et c'est bien qu'il les fasse
de cette manière là le ménage plus
modeste sera pas posé ce geste parce que
son reste à charge sera trop grand si on
lui trouve une solution
qui lui permet de poser un premier geste
pas très coûteux qui lui permet de
réduire sa facture et d'augmenter sa
capacité de faire des gestes le plus
importants après il me semble que chez
un chemin très très intéressant et
deuxièmement c'est pas parce que ce
geste
est beaucoup moins coûteux
que les 20 à 30% d'efficacité
énergétique qu'il induit
sont de moins bonne qualité que les 20 à
30% de l'efficacité énergétique d'autres
gestes beaucoup plus coûteux
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Directeur et
encore désolé pour pour ce retard et
merci de vos explications
merci